[Music]
do
sup hello everyone welcome
today we're playing more of deadly
premonition 2
a blessing in disguise i believe is the
full title of the video game
um i left off exactly where the last
stream was i haven't played it at all i
need to change my uh
display settings that text is too small
there we go um
how do i catch you up to speed on what's
been happening
okay uh well this woman
who i've been calling hot karen as it
would turn out
um has
chopped her daughter up with an axe and
then put her
inside of uh a warehouse
freezer that her family also owns
plot twist um it seems like someone kind
of made her do it and also she's insane
now
uh i think it's mrs r
i don't remember what the character's
name is so that's like what we're
holding the tails of now
um that's the simple version the
extended version
is that i found a talking painting
bear with me that told me to
um find
i had to like top all the ten maidens
which it turns out was a bowling alley
but the woman who was bowling there i
couldn't get her to leave the lane
so i went to a voodoo store and bought
her an alligator with a top hat and put
it in front of her house in the hopes
that it would like maybe stop her from
coming bowling
as early the next day and it did and i
got a strike
um otherwise it was something to do with
like temperatures i don't know
i think that's pretty much it i think
we're pretty much up to speed
so you're all caught up we're trying to
figure out like who made this woman
murder her daughter is
the gist of the mystery um also
we travel to another dimension at one
point
so that was pretty cool
goddamn ridiculous video game
um but yeah you know it's deadly
premonition it is what it is
you know what to expect uh let me
make sure everything is working i am not
explaining an acid trip
pop jake this is literally what happens
in this video game
so okay let's go shall we
uh my current objective is to go back to
the hotel
i love that his footsteps sound
identical no matter what surface you're
walking on
it's really a pinnacle of game design
we've already hit our first oh really
moment
and it is i have to press a
i can't just walk upstairs to be fair if
you play deadly premonition one
the stairs in that game are so funny
because
there's this like weird perspective
issue wait you can walk up the stairs in
the hotel but there's this weird
perspective issue in the first game
where it like
everyone who tries to walk up a
staircase tends to spin it's very hard
to explain why it's a problem
thank you pugs are big that means i did
a really good job of explaining it uh
demetrius is that shells
cel-shaded graphics no
no it isn't
um i don't think this quite counts
what you doing there bud your hands
aren't on your knees i know you think
they are but they ain't
do you are you waiting for someone like
bring you a keyboard
like what is also just a lot of
questions about
your upper body in general really um
oh look at his his legs don't even touch
the ground his little feet
all right well i'm sorry for picking on
you have a good day what you doing
what is that uh
are you
at least with her
it like at least sort of a little bit
looks like she's just looking at her
nails i could believe that
it's melvin hey buddy hey there mr york
looking sharp as usual what'll it be
oh i need to put my delay on the game's
gonna be off hang on give me a second
[Music]
microphone has to be 500 milliseconds
delayed webcam filters render delay
done that should fix it okay
um what will it be oh well i wasn't
actually planning on talking to him but
here we are
okay
it's so weird that it jumps between
sometimes being fully voiced and
sometimes doing this but
optional stuff they just didn't voice i
guess
he's doing our favorite animation is he
writing us a poem
is that what's happening
killer bees
i haven't seen any of those
do i feel like getting rich i don't know
that i need it actually i have so much
money for no reason
and i just keep eating ice cream
credit cards don't walk in this town
[Music]
okay
i don't think that's true i feel like
that's a lie
uh nars are you joking you think this is
the most boring game ever
i think someone said that last time if
there's anything i've ever wanted to say
um about deadly premonition it is that
it is the opposite of boring
um could somebody fact-check this for me
have bees always held a spot in the list
for the creatures that killed the
greatest number of human beings
because i feel like that might be a lie
so
uh yeah i guess people are allergic to
these things allergies is a thing that
makes sense
i still doubt it i still call [ __ ]
all right cool
i guess i just said yes i don't i guess
i'm doing that then
there's a time limit i don't want to do
that at all
not even a little bit uh i should save
oh this game does have a lot of auto
save so maybe i don't need to
sure we're out of safe slots there are
not many of them also why is it doing
this i'm just gonna let it auto safe
then
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna not
bother with any of that stuff it's fine
apparently over 17 years some bees have
only killed over a thousand people there
you go
heard it on youtube first ladies and
gentlemen it must be true that's how it
works
fax fax
loading screens take a while don't worry
about it featuring not a bug
not a big deal we love to see it
yay goes to tsushima i make that choke
every time
an annual average of 62 deaths i feel
like that is not
the highest of any animal i feel like
york lied i think
generally he's pretty spot on but in
this instance
think he's full of [ __ ] um hey nick uh
go [ __ ] yourself
uh people who come in and tell me to
change my hair to go for yourself
pay attention to the video game i'm not
doing [ __ ] for you
person i don't know all right good day
oh i've been trying to get this
sunscreen for so long because it looks
like it'll make me hot
because it looks like him but buff right
but i'm not sunburned yet
what is this okay new york
what do you think of my cat oh well yeah
we've seen him
i've been curious about it since the
first time i saw it already i think you
got excellent taste melvin
it's definitely not invader
absolutely not a thing i'll have you
know crawfish is pretty much its own
food group in this town
since this store carries all the bare
necessities you'll need for daily life
i reckon it was an app name if it's
sundries you're looking for
there ain't much you won't find here
okay
what you got dude i don't think i need
anything oh my hp's a bit low
so sure all right
let's just take a couple of those i
guess cool that you can only buy one at
a time i love it when video games do
that
oh we do want cigarettes
oh let's get some heavy cigarettes shall
we
that seems good you ever need anything
you're not only the sheriff of this town
you also manage a general store
sure as long as you ring this bell here
that's terribly convenient melvin but i
have one concern
of course you do francis joke morgan of
course you have one concerned
what if a crime occurs while you're
managing the store running a business
and keeping the peace
both jobs require immediate response in
times of crisis
okay he's technically right yeah just
can't see how it would be possible
it's actually pretty easy mr york but
what if a criminal who just robbed a
bank
came here on his way home and bought up
all your stock you feel about that
melvin oh
i like the sound of that you want to
make me rich
hey how about you just buy up the whole
store while you're at it
i'll never let money stand in my way
it's not the boss of me
oh my god i am the last shopper
oh i love him a lot
i don't know if i would have said funny
but i do love you melvin that was a
serious question
really could have fooled me the
voice acting's not bad
it's not like i they do i feel like it
works
it's not an issue
[Music]
not even the clarkson's would do
something that crazy
well one of them literally killed their
daughter so
maybe they've been wrong this is lucario
the tiny forgotten town in the middle of
southern nowhere get it zach it's
occam's razor to a t
what melvin i have to say you're a very
balanced man
what does that mean
now i feel confident that the woods
household will do just fine even if you
end up losing your job as town sheriff
okay you sure are a joker mr york
i'm already confused and concerned i
could use the fast travel with the hot
chick
let's do that let's use it let's let's
do it
oh i have to activate them maybe i can't
then because i probably haven't
activated any others
bro we want to go back to the hotel yeah
this is gonna be fast travel let's see
how fast it is you ready
heart check doesn't show up that's
actually devastating zero out of ten
worst video game i've ever played
uh yes landon this sheriff sell
sunscreen out of a van you're officially
caught up
that is exactly what's happening yes
okay
i feel like i'm probably gonna end up
going to that jazz ball
let's do it i feel like that's the next
step is we saw a stylish tall woman
in a deadly premonition of the murder
that occurred that brought us to this
town
and uh this is also selling sunscreen oh
no that's breakfast
we've already eaten there oh yeah
inventory
minus no that's map inventory
uh i don't remember what button it is
[Music]
you'd think it would be that but it
ain't it's why
it's why that's right okay
um we can just take a small
first aid kit i think that should be
fine oh i mean the hotel is
[ __ ] slipped what am i doing i'm just
looking after my boy it's fine
okay i kind of expect someone to be
waiting in here for me
oh we're good okay why am i here
to look at this wall all right great
great i can't wait i can't wait to see
what's going to happen i can't wait
let's go over our
skype card this is a switch exclusive
only on switch
hi chris
it may as well be will it may as well be
we've got a complicated case on our
hands this time
especially as far as the clarkson's
relationships go
but in a way it's also a simple one
understanding them on a deeper level is
the most efficient way to uncover the
truth behind all this
if you say so the one thing i'm sure of
okay
great notes so far
well you added a lot zach let's start
with the people who were closest to the
victim
okay lisa clarkson the victim is the
granddaughter of the current head of the
clarkson family
are they like like a mob have we decided
they're like
like mafia her mother is galena an
ex-actress and elise clearly inherited
her beauty
you're not wrong but unnecessary except
for her eyes that is
lisa's eye color matches that of her
father's now
do you remember who elise clarkson's
father is yeah i was that shitty dude
who like threatened us or whatever
oh [ __ ] danny i think
that's right lisa's father is danny
clarkson
hopefully i don't run into any bugs are
you kidding mal pal
this game is like 90 bucks
his real name is daniel e clarkson
he's from florida and used to be the ceo
of a talent agency danny struck the
heart of galena and successfully became
a member of the esteemed clarkson family
how did you find this out despite being
where was i when you figured this out
acts like he was born a clarkson
but he's still just the son-in-law
but how shitty that dude was i'm
surprised he was willing to do that
according to
alexis lee said that the man was as tall
as an oak
oh yeah sorry i forgot to catch you guys
up on the fact that the woman who was
murdered said that the person who killed
her
was as tall as an oak tree which i guess
means that it can't have been galena
slash karen
um and there was like evidence that
someone that moved her body
inside of the frieza warehouse was like
an actual giant
so we're kind of looking for an actual
giant also
i believe that's the same 10 foot tall
giant who made the fingerprints we found
in the cold storage warehouse
now what did this man do to lease prior
to her murder
stopped her stole a chocolate sundae
everyone's favorite cajun food yes
that's it zack
the man as tall as an oak tree followed
lisa around and watched her
have i played halo 3 at alternate on pc
uh no oh my god my game was
my day was so busy but i did actually
vlog my whole day today
i wanted to do like a day in the life of
quarantine thing
um so that will be a probably saturday
i'll edit it
despite his towering stature he must
have been rather shy
or perhaps he was merely biding his time
and planned to kidnap her from the very
start perhaps
if that's the case there should have
been some evidence left at the scene of
the crime which was
under a bridge um zach we're still
missing some puzzle pieces i agree i
actually completely forgot about the 10
foot tall man because we didn't we have
literal premonition why we saw galena do
it or was the 10-foot tall man
the boss that she turned into which did
kind of look like a tree
speaking of the scene of the crime i did
some profiling in the plantation's
control room
the truth it revealed to us was
nauseating and horrific was it
but we need to touch upon it if we wish
to proceed okay isn't that right zach
oh yeah that was where she got exempted
yes that's actually murdered lisa
clarkson
[Music]
yes that's right lisa's own mother
killed her
while she was dreaming about some
bizarre new world
frankly lise at the time sounded like
she was having an orgasm
i don't feel like we should just put
that aside that was pretty weird this is
by far
the vilest and ugliest crime we've ever
seen the fact that galena set up her
daughter's
remember not a single sacrificial human
murder
has ever been proven and documented in
all of american history
is that true i don't believe you after
the bees thing i feel like you often say
a lot of things that are true but that
one i feel like might be [ __ ]
the real world is far more complex than
what we see in films and video games
is that are you breaking the fourth wall
is that a cell phone and sacrificing a
human life for something else
is no easy task i think he's lying i
think he's politicians
through our investigation we found one
character who sticks out more than
anyone else
every you know exactly who i'm thinking
about don't you someone who's to oh uh
mrs oh or whatever we'll need to have a
word with her in the near future
who's the stylish woman we saw oh god
it's gonna make me guess that i don't
know what it is professor
well well thankfully they're all exactly
the same
professor r that was very helpful we
haven't met her yet
but she's deeply intertwined with this
case okay let's wait for the skeletal
gentleman to guide us to
her with an oracle
okay yeah well zack what do you think
isn't the deep south something
so okay the people here are just as warm
as the weather
and the food is to die for it might be
nice to move down here after i retire
okay what still too early to talk about
no i'm just very weird
you may be right after all because i
don't feel like anyone really talks like
that i don't feel like people go to the
deep south and say
say isn't it nice being in the deep
south
here where we are in the deep south he
just brings it up a lot it's almost like
this game was written by a japanese man
[Music]
10 i'm rich i don't need to kill no bees
all right we did it game solved
what you do think people talk about the
deep south all the time in the deep
south one video game dude
i just don't know if that's true where
is york in present time drewboo's york
in
like the furthest forward that i've seen
is i think he lives in boston
the south is like that's i'm sorry i
should have left the south check to you
guys
um i shouldn't have doubted doubted you
i should know that you guys know
what's up with the south so
it makes sense
all right well it's a loading screen so
i know boston's not in the deep south
i'm just saying
that's where i'm pretty sure he lives
now what is this galena can't be the
killer oh
they're making all this [ __ ] up this is
danny
okay okay
yeah cool yeah i love the deep south
why is your face moving but this is what
you say is perfectly still how do you
plan to prove it
oh gosh who are you it's nearly been a
century
since the clarksons first took control
of lucario
100 years
i always thought my legacy would live on
for two
no 300 at least
i'm gonna find the real killer and beat
the living dog [ __ ] out of them
yet it looks to me like times have
changed the same thing
ain't in the good old days no more
understand me boy yes sir
i'm right there with you paul i'm gonna
continue what you started sir
and make the clarkson family strong
again
first i need to find whoever really
killed lease
and pass their [ __ ] brains in i don't
know that that's
that's good of an action plan but yes
this is the deep south obviously
left home the town of lucari
has been cursed um
is that the sun maybe it's beyond me
no it's beyond the minds of anyone who
comes from the olden days
you understand me now when it comes from
the olden days yes sir
believe me i do i'll kill you oh my gosh
just leave
everything to me paul
are you serious about this yes sir
right hand to god look right in my eyes
i ain't lying
i'm serious i just need you he looks
like one of those
dances they do on tick-tock retribution
right now
which that's the job i have more
opinions on than you would think
but we'll get to that when the cutscene
ends let me ask you one more time
are you serious about it why is your
whole hair vibrate
hell yeah this guy's fine i'm a clarkson
and all clarkson's have a job to do
is that what we always say um
then i'll need an arm yeah what
what well now you want to use my
troops i'm gonna need to know whether or
not
you're really serious about this
just one arm slide it on through that
wire there
and it'll take care of it for you
paul i mean you're joking right
daniel have i ever told you
a single joke
no okay but
if you want to become a real clarkson
and you done gotcha stop asking
questions it's fine it's fine it's fight
oh my god wait paul
i get it now you you want me to stick it
in and pull it out at the last minute
right
you you want to see if i got guts or not
but
there's going to be another way
oh my god okay serious sir
knock it off yes hoes let me go
he's just joking with me let me go god
damn it
i thought that please sir don't do that
i misunderstood just tell me this is a
joke please
that was literally a screenshot it was
freeze frame
[Music]
oh my god
i am a clarkson
and no matter how our fortune falls
all clarkson's have a job to do
well i feel like he could have job done
the job with two arms
[Music]
okay no it's fine yeah it makes sense i
understood what just happened
oh well at least i'm immediately
distracted from what was just happening
okay
[Music]
why
[Music]
it's just so much information this video
game is just so much
[ __ ] bizarre information all the time
and it's
difficult to just process oh my god
um okay don't ask questions just let it
happen
just let it happen
uh oh that's the end of episode one we
are not even going to try to explain
that
okay
well then
here we are i guess um what
[Music]
you can hear right i'll be with you
soon okay cool i'm not sad
[Music]
honestly i can't wait
look that's all i think about lately
[Music]
i mean we'll be together again it's fine
i'm not even going to
discuss movies food again why are they
separated
around here if you haven't seen
they don't understand things i just
realized that
it's doing this again no matter where i
hold
it can only walk forward that reminds me
it's on it's on rails
there are movie theaters and restaurants
over there right
yep
peanut butter hamburgers wait does that
sound good
i have no idea um okay
oh it's old man
york
please no exactly of course
you just need to wait a bit longer i
still have
one job left to do i need to finish it
i have to was it the point of the end of
the first game that they separated like
permanently
just give me a little more time okay
if he's old there then that's not gonna
make any sense
to any of you who haven't played the
first game don't worry about it oh okay
we're in the future again
oh i hate this [ __ ] oh my god it's so
bad this is what the first hour of the
game looks like and it's the water's
mother galena clarkson confessed to
murdering least just give me the
the good bits but yeah basically this
is zach he's stoned as [ __ ]
being interviewed by two detectives
about the case that way then
flashing back to see um i hate this
stuff
[Music]
but then immediately afterwards she went
insane
so you had no choice but to detain her
what a terribly convenient story you
were the first person to find the
suspect hiding at a farm on the edge of
town
kalina yeah no i was and you even got
her to confess to the crime
right then and there did anyone else get
a chance to hear galena's confession
the [ __ ] is this only us
how did you even find that check in the
first place
talking painting probably i don't
remember actually
i hate this [ __ ] so much like if i were
reviewing this game i feel like
it would be split on like the parts of
the game that are video game
and then this stuff which
is just awful metaphysical offender
profiling
meta what should i know this word it's
just
dial up with people i don't care about
just
metaphysical offender profiling
the term appears six times in the lucare
report
and 14 times in the 2010 green shout out
to greenville
that's the first game as long as you're
solving cases the people in charge don't
really care what sort of words you use
but we're different you utilized a
highly abnormal method to
instantly hone in on a suspect it was a
talking painting because that was that
[ __ ] was pretty weird
[Music]
what's making me stay do you mean are
you talking to each other
canadian goose are you talking to me
[Music]
uh i mean i
i actually genuinely very much like this
game
um oh like playing it this stuff i don't
like but i can't
not play it i have to play through this
flash forward stuff to get
back to the flashback part with which i
like but no like don't get me wrong
this game is uh
a broken mess but it is a very fun time
to play i
definitely like it i just don't like
this bit
then you did it again and every time you
used it
one term kept appearing in your files
metaphysical offender profiling
to be fair i don't [ __ ] know that
means either mr morgan would you mind
explaining to us what this term means
why couldn't you just ask him in a
shorter sense
okay but no matter what words we used
you'd never be able to understand sick
dude you see
it doesn't pertain to this i think
uh the reason that i hate this so much
is that they kind of make york shitty
whereas in the first game he's actually
like really
nice and lovable whereas in this he's
just like kind of a douchebag
why does he look like a mommy this is
aesthetic don't worry about it
come my fairy stop hiding back there and
give them the explanation they so desire
yeah
they made my favorite favorite character
or like a character that i like from
video games a lot just like this shitty
old stoner dude
what is a bomber you're too shy
mr morgan yep
mr morgan yes hello come on don't be
is that all you have to say
underestimate me morgan oh she thought
that i know you and the clarkson share a
deeper connection yes
much deeper than how it appears on the
surface yeah
uh yes mike the frame rate is absolutely
as bad as everyone says
also yes coinsell that is the guy from
the first one that is that is him
yep i need to shake him with something
else this is what happens when you smoke
weed
don't do drugs immediately you smoke
weed you'll turn out looking like this
guy
i'm going to jog your memory buff well
your forehead grows and you lose all of
your hair i don't think his even
entire head is even that big it's
somehow like expanded upwards
so don't smoke weed
[ __ ] okay
okay got it let's do that one the
look feature lets me pick whatever it is
that'll get me through the story
which generally i don't want to do but
in this yeah this flashback i totally do
according to you at the beginning of
this case the victim's body was being
stored in the warehouse on purpose
correct
is that the truth yeah they really put
her body there alongside food and other
perishables they don't have a morgantown
so it's in the report no
the report only says it was stored using
the most effective and shockingly
inhuman method
possible it is pretty inhuman actually
to be fair if you can think of a better
phrase
we're all ears the report isn't wrong
you know
oh i love simon in fact that might
actually be the most
accurate way of describing it okay it's
precise
why am i here poet
why
wow simon
right oh they're floating you didn't
think i'm [ __ ] so what's happening
here
are we seeing courtship happen in real
time
all right you two think this is a joke
jealous that's jealousy forever i've
seen it which one of them are you trying
to bang
who are you jealous of who least would
like which man
was discovered in that cold storage
warehouse after 14
long years wait what okay that doesn't
make sense 14 years because i'm pretty
sure that they
i remember this from the start of the
game that
right no okay okay okay her body was
missing
she was stored in the warehouse and then
her body went missing and then i guess
it came back
14 years later if you'd only done a
proper investigation
we probably would have thought he just
didn't find it but they said the body
was missing is what happened
that poor girl we still regret the fact
that we never got to meet her
we're sorry from the bottoms of our
hearts
i only hope it didn't happen that way by
design i try to sound
old i just sort of get croaky
that's how it works basically
you just have to will you comfort me
comfort me
will you speak like this
thank you my favorite no worries dude i
[ __ ] got you
[ __ ] all right just give me the hacks
come on
it's not that there's gonna be
old messy letters then that's the only
thing in here right
i guess so okay
those letters look very old why is this
happening
[Music]
the postmark suggests they were sent out
from louisiana oh [ __ ]
and i suspect that dragonfly mark
belongs to the clarkson family
that's interesting
[Music]
maybe [ __ ] nailed the delivery on
that line you know they were in the
booth and they were like
yes dude killed it we love the um
maybe not that he's a bad voice actor
for the record he's actually quite good
but
yeah i just you know can't help but dunk
on things she's my brand if it does
a stalker has been harassing patricia
clarkson for several years now
you won did you know about this is it an
oak tree
[Music]
constant silent phone calls unmarked
letters
she also spotted a suspicious figure
lurking near her mansion center
the size of a tree and just last week
her employees spotted a strange figure
lurking in the vicinity
the day someone else coincidentally used
your alias
and traveled to louisiana
that's very intriguing oh
lis clarkson also reported being
harassed by us i recall i recall she was
murdered yeah
you're aware of this correct
because i didn't find any mention of
this in your report i feel like i have
conflicting information in that her mom
killed her but then did she not
actually because right what is up with
the 10-foot tall man
but then we saw in the premonition that
my mom did it and she confessed
so
you know no direct connection to the
case
that's what we must have thought the
visionary lies to himself
the which are you
that's enough for now this all has
nothing to do with the case
besides there's no evidence that proves
those letters are from her
isn't that right my fairy
i knew it wouldn't go that easily i just
don't know why
i should try asking your history i could
use agent jones here
okay what else do you want me to look at
let's do it
okay you literally told me what to do is
ask simon nervous simon
very cute agent jones
are you paying attention furiously
masturbating look at his hands
or do you intend to waste mr morgan's
precious time so aggressive
uh no stop bullying everyone i'm
just a little tired i'm listening i'm
listening
take your hand out of your pocket it's
pretty gross dude
didn't they teach you any manners at
quantico she's right she got you there
uh
right guess they slipped my mind also
though in what world is
having your hands in your pockets
impolite
i also want her to humiliate me yeah
um
[Music]
yeah i don't know that that's considered
polite or impolite sorry
uh oh what's happening with her leg
her hand is very much inside of her knee
feature not about my bad
[Music]
i'm actually kind of nervous i'm not
used to this sort of thing
okay data analysis is my perspective
then why the [ __ ] are you here simon
uh yeah i'm sure i'd be able to calm
down a bit
if i had some pizza though
[Laughter]
i hate this stuff so much
the fbi needs to do something about
their lack of personnel
i'll have to ask the questions myself
but how should
i start maybe i should look back over
the files and
if you say so i wasted that one it's the
only option
damn it after you arrested galena
clarkson
you had a run-in with the clarkson's
okay at least that's what it says in the
report
what exactly happened there just a
simple run-in that's all
nothing but a single phenomenon what
does that even mean
chasing hollow instances like that won't
lead you closer to the truth
i don't even know what truth she's after
if i'm being completely honest truth
doesn't work i don't know why these
people are actually interviewing him
a hollow phenomenon which resulted in a
mountain of corpses
oh [ __ ] okay all mouth isn't coming i'd
love to see it
if you're francis not me
i hate that you think we finally
understand what you're trying to say
but don't be so voracious
okay okay
how about another cup of coffee
sherman we still got a long way to go
you know i don't know what we're here
for what is that in the corner
a clock and
no idea what those are the things like
right above me
what is that
i don't know
yes it's coarsely ground so
there should only be four teaspoons per
cup thank you
no more no less next the coffee travels
from the funnel
to the siphon simon normally you only do
surveillance in order to gather data
correct hiding microphones and cameras
oh yeah that's right he was shifting
through guards
shadowing you'll do whatever it takes to
gather data in order to prevent crimes
that's how the fbi works okay uh
well yeah you're right okay no reason in
hiding it now i guess
[Music]
why do you ask our southern belle has
adopted a very peculiar mo
who are you referring to simon you guys
are hitting on each other
it's almost like oh damn it not hard
special i don't ship this
you've been watching us this entire the
way he turned around he looks terrifying
[Music]
from that window well yeah we already
knew that it's been like four years
i don't need to answer that question you
came here on new year's eve
and spent 49 hours watching us until you
returned to your hotel room last night
oh maybe it's 49 hours and not four
years very different uh
amounts of time a lot of i'm not sure
though you i feel like it was a long
time
the entire time without sleep or rest
i guess what what is happening is that
they think that he's like involved in
more likari murders but i don't know why
they didn't just like kind of ask him
like why has it been so elaborate and
weird and like aggressive
you know and you only ate once some
pizza delivered like it's just
everyone's passing aggressive and
dancing around each other i just don't
know why
aside from that you never drank any
water or relieved yourself
you simply sat there and continued to
watch us
like everyone might be bad at their jobs
you have oh sorry
visions two don't you you came here
solely to hear us talk didn't you how
did he even jump to that conclusion stop
asking questions let it happen
that has to be my motto for this game or
my brain starts to sort of explode stop
asking questions
just let it happen but then why bother
watching us
for over two days before that's a good
question you didn't come to talk with us
you came because you wanted to see this
apartment
with your own eyes got it okay cool and
because you're already convinced of
something
confirmation bias is a real [ __ ] isn't
that right
he who fights with monsters should see
to it
that he himself does not become a
monster
okay and if you gaze long into an abyss
the abyss also gazes into you
i was just thinking oh
coffee but i oh
coffee what happened to your head
i just don't thank you my face his head
doesn't look like that in
the past if you hadn't been paying
attention this
coffee would have all gone to waste yeah
no worries dude [ __ ] for you
[Music]
the puss in our brains it really has a
way of interfering
with our lives that's just the weed dude
that is just the weed
i promise okay can i be out of this hell
put me back in the game
beam me up scotty [ __ ]
um no karang you don't need to look up
the first game to understand what's
happening
you absolutely do not um that's a lie
christ
this what's the question delicious i
kinda thought i was gonna
chit myself for a second there
[Music]
i thought that what the christ was a
stupid bizarre thing to say i bet he
said i thought i was gonna [ __ ] myself
for a second there
as a testament to enthusiasm
okay come on perfect take a sip it's the
best thing
i'm not exaggerating here i'm just not
saying that
if i find anything just like vaguely
good like the next time i have a call
i'm just gonna stop being like i thought
i was gonna [ __ ] myself for a second
there and just see if people
react and recognize that i am trying to
say something positive
actually if i ever review a game again
i'll be like uh
honestly i was playing through ghost
sushima and
i thought i was gonna [ __ ] myself for a
second there just
see if people are picking up on what i'm
saying
um just see if that's the thing that is
as possible
in this as they think also yes those are
milk cartons taped together
warm don't worry about it milk bomb
why do you think so he was going to
shoot himself i don't believe it
fk in the coffee it's better than any
coffee i've ever tasted
you didn't even you didn't even put it
in your mouth i solo the whole thing of
course it is
coffee is a sacred drink okay
coffee saved us okay
if not for its oracle we would be on the
other side right now
that is technically a reference to the
first game that technically does make
sense and i kind of get it
so i never forget to pay my respects to
coffee
especially at critical moments like this
big black cumulonimbus clouds are in the
sky what
sometimes i just have to like give
myself a second while i'm playing this
you know
um who says that okay continue
he's still sitting there with his
friends
what is that oh my
god okay okay we're fine it's fine
ah [ __ ] oh you want me to look at the
clouds you want me to look at the clouds
okay apparently that's what we have to
do to progress the story
for some reason do you hear that thunder
it's probably going to snow soon is that
how that works
people who live in the snow can i get a
snow check
there's no check please um i'm gonna
need to know if that's legit or is she
talking [ __ ]
uh anyone who lives in anywhere called
snow check
apparently no you passed you passed the
call check not a real thing
look at massachusetts that's the norm
for this time of year you know what i
have been to massachusetts
in the winter and that [ __ ] does get
very snowy and i almost got snowed in
one time
well i'm not using apparently unrelated
to to to
possible i'd like to finish this up
before we get stuck in a snow storm
agent i would love you to finish this up
i really like agent jones is something
that matters he's just masturbating
there's so much sexual tension between
him and
zack i guess now which again sort of
undoes the ending of the first game
which is very confusing to me um
hopefully it's explained
that's it's fine um but you know and
then he nearly shot himself
in a positive way look i've never seen
someone so clearly masturbating before
in my life
look at him are you you know what's
happening
snap out of it oh sorry
yeah i know i know do you then stop
daydreaming
okay okay think of all the activities he
could do with that forehead
i just you just what
i just uh my stomach's been letting some
thunder loose
too what the [ __ ]
it's like i'm struggling to get through
this like i feel like i'm falling apart
like am i awake is this
real i might
be dreaming um
okay thunder the uh
that coffee was just so good it
uh it what we don't have
the coffee was just so good it uh
summoned forth a massive tsunami from
within me
i'm also gonna say that whenever i
review a game um you know if i ever do
it again i haven't done it for a long
time
uh here's how you will know if i think a
game is like a 10 out of 10 also a score
i've never given but if i did
i would say i thought i was going to
shut myself there for a second
and it summoned forth a massive tsunami
from within me
that's how you know something is like
the best you've ever had
um obviously everyone's gonna understand
excuse me what is wrong with you now is
really not the time for this well okay
to be fair
aaliyah if someone's gonna [ __ ]
themselves it's like not like he's doing
it on purpose
[Music]
right door at the end of the hallway
thanks pal
okay
we promise you we did not put laxatives
in the coffee
[Music]
coffee is a sacred drink okay yeah
that's right it did tell you
you know who the murderer was or
whatever
[ __ ]
okay there's no doubt that the report
omitted information linking morgan to
the clarkson
i need to get him to confess there's a
secret weapon in agent jones's briefcase
okay great let's take a look at whatever
that is
have you ever seen this before and
please don't say no
what if the answer is literally though
though the drug we once chased
what about it saul rouge is still
circulating it's changed shape and its
composition is slightly different now
but it's still very much alive uh
relevant because
at least the girl who died i think was
on the drug
while being mutted but only in a very
limited part of louisiana
you aren't surprised did you somehow
know this would happen
no are you trying to imply that he's
become a drug dealer because if yes
[ __ ] you my son rouge is special
the inimitable enigma powder the origin
it has many names and no one was ever
able to copy it this isn't breaking bad
[ __ ] is that what's happening
it's a very good combo to keep it very
nice uh yes
san rouge is red powder i i don't think
he's smoking this on rouge because
it doesn't have that effect i don't
think we've also been trying to figure
out what it's made from ever since it
appeared but it's impossible to analyze
after all it appears to be made from
common ingredients that can be found
anywhere
then why does that make it possible to
analyze but if you try to use those
ingredients all you'll end up with is a
mundane hallucinogen
like dmt if you're lucky it's very
mysterious
thank you 77 madman appreciate that no
sal rouge requires a special recipe
the original recipe which someone's been
guarding this entire time
if what's happening in this game is that
york somehow became a [ __ ] drug
dealer
it's gonna take me like months to
process that will last me until the rest
of
isolation until i come to terms with
that
someone who survived the incident in
lucare
i don't have any left we're going to go
with
indulgence mr morgan
i heard that you were always a smart
correct did you ever wonder if that was
the reason you contracted your illness
what's his illness
[Music]
it just made a sound what does that
have to do with this case nothing i'm
just personally well aliyah could you
stop [ __ ] around please
sometimes people die in car accidents
regardless of how well they take care of
their health rough but true
other times they slip on their bathroom
floors and crack open their heads that's
true yes isn't that right my fairy not
wrong i'm not concerned with statistics
i'm just curious about you right we
switched over from
nicotine to this it's less addictive
that's one step in the right direction
isn't it i don't know
perhaps if we're talking about
withdrawal symptoms or physical
dependencies
but it still seems like you're smoking
too much at once honestly it looks to me
like you have a mental dependency
why are we talking about this i don't
understand why this is happening
thank you pete same
maybe but why is this happening
surely you know about gateway drugs yes
what the [ __ ]
why is this here i just don't understand
why was this a thing that they wrote
into this game
i you know
when a person starts to use one drug it
becomes much
easier for them to branch out and try
other drugs as well
well that's not exactly the logic but
okay the first drug
acts as the gateway that leads them to
it doesn't make it easier it just kind
of gets you involved
oh are you trying to say
that's going to happen to us
no i'm simply right then why'd you
[ __ ] say it
oh my god okay fine all messy lettuce it
is
immediately after they found lisa's body
i went to go see patricia
in order to interrogate her of course
yeah you tell that [ __ ]
so you told us but i was unable to meet
with her she refused to speak with you
didn't she
that's so like her no she didn't get the
chance to
you see she's gone missing what
to put it more accurately no one's seen
her since the afternoon of the 28th
what date is it today like the first on
the second i think according to her
employees she shut herself up in her
room for several months before she
disappeared
she was being stalked by an oak tree but
since that sort of thing happened
often they didn't think anything of it
on the morning of new year's eve they
noticed her window was open
and when they went up to check on her
she was gone but
no one knows how long her window had
been open for
okay uh okay okay i could question that
but whatever but on december 28th
a strange man visited le carre and was
spotted near her mansion
where she only had one window that man
must have found some way to lure
patricia into his car
it was probably massive titties the 89
cadillac that he bought
used then the two of them drove north to
trenton where they boarded a train oh
he's trying to imply she's trying to
imply that that that uh
york slash zach did this oh thank you
shadowed folks i'm more excited about
ghost tsushima cyberpunk i'm already
playing tsushima so
cyberpunk they would have arrived here
around midnight on the 29th
or perhaps early morning on the 30th um
jack said why the commentator need to
feel the need to show their face
with this game especially i feel like
you want to see my reactions but maybe
it's just me if you would like me to
turn the webcam off i can
but i feel like the reactions probably
at
i believe this man is the same billy
bishop whose name was previously
recorded by the airline
she thinks that this is uh i don't know
what to call him now
francis so what do you think of my guess
i'd love to hear your opinion as a
former fbi
specialist everything she say sounds so
sassy
i don't now we get it they aren't
persons of interest
we're the suspects but what about our
alibi
what alibi
i've had enough of your [ __ ] you
expect me to believe you haven't taken a
single step out of this room
that agent they really look up to all
this huh
surveillance cameras can easily be
tampered with
all right especially by someone like you
who knows
all about how the fbi works
why that's in his apartment you've just
done that
you're possessed by death go and take a
look at your own
face in the mirror why are you you
looking like the grim right what the
[ __ ] dude
after you visited both lucare and
greenvale you left a mountain of corpses
in your wake
you can make all the excuses you want
i'm immune to them
right here right now i want to know
everything
you're good bill damn good
you're brimming with potassium oh my god
don't you think she's the perfect
partner for our last dance
what do you say my fairy don't you agree
she's good
so good
what do you want to know we've got
nothing to do did you turn into gold
questions are you this is how it's got
to be
doesn't this remind you of something you
know what i mean my fairy
he's on drugs right now more than he was
before and he looks like a [ __ ]
zombie
oh
okay i guess we're just gonna leave that
interaction
yeah that's actually pretty [ __ ] up
melvin
i feel like i'm just going to forget
everything that happened in the previous
scene
lined up according to the lines that
were drawn with her bloody [ __ ] [ __ ]
just like migratory birds flying
systematically across the sky
exactly what do you think this means
they're severed roots get the [ __ ] out
of here severed roots
this is the way the clarkson's kills
someone when they want to cut him off
from the family saying danny did that
and how do you know about this
everyone in town knows about it that's
[ __ ] up they're just too scared to
talk that's insane that's completely
insane what how many modes do you have
what does the v
stand for then it's me
what you think i know everything for
gene
villa oh sure it means quarrel and latin
oh that's what the v that's what i meant
yeah totally latin
intriguing isn't it zack
there are no defense wounds on the
course in other words
galena showed no signs of resistance
when she was amputated
same as uh strangely enough there are
small traces of subcutaneous bleeding
around the wounded areas
that's a vital reaction which means she
couldn't have been dead
got it i have watched a lot of forensic
files in my time yes that's right patty
i think we watched like 300
series while she was still alive and she
never resisted
is that even possible yes if she was on
sorry it isn't
impossible for example if she was put to
sleep with a drug
or if she desired the amputation herself
why would she ever desire that what does
she have is it just one
offers all of it i'm sorry but there
ain't no way that could have happened
how can you be sure of that melvin our
world contains phenomena that could
never be explained with logic
this is especially true for phenomena in
which humans are involved
do you really think all the facets of
love and hate can be explained with
logic
well uh no i
i don't reckon i do yeah
might be too early to rule out those
possibilities just like you say
zack now we truly know just how deeply
the clarksons are involved with this
how has this been happening in this town
does it take to reach the clarkson
um just a short drive but how long by
skateboarding gotta head west along the
mississippi
but how long by skateboarding can't miss
it got it
thank you pam useless party how long is
it going to take me to escape by the way
melvin
no matter how accelerated patty may be
don't you think she's still a bit too
young to see something like this
yeah for the record i have no intent to
instruct others on how to raise their
children well you'll still be a
judgemental assault about it
holy moly you're right
patricia clg come on he is right
i agree you shouldn't have to see stuff
like this
daddy it's too late now
also true a bunch of geniuses we got out
here
how long is it gonna take me a
skateboard
chance chance chance okay
bye oh [ __ ] can't walk up the stairs
stupid video okay
okay
let's roll no there's no sprint
oh you're back what are you doing
checking your nails out how do they look
did you get them done i love that they
animated her breathing but didn't
pose so correctly oh
i always think it's a freeze but it's
just a cut scene
okay
he's back
the oracle
yes you found the blind serpent
i did but now the flag serpent
will come to fight anyone who's just
joining this now must be super [ __ ]
sounds
and it looks like this flying serpent is
a venomous one
this is a real thing that's happening
some become
feasts while others are eaten alive
is that a new riddle which feat would
you prefer
both sound marvelous but let me check
with zach
okay a fine answer
like that answer means anything to
anyone find the one who fired the pistol
at heaven okay within the white hole of
beds
brandished the ticket why holidays
and once again you will see the other
word
great i want to see the other world
that's where i saw the crap
comprehend the oracle yeah dude i'm
picking up we put down
zack it looks like he's hell-bent on
leading us back into that other world
follow the oracle oh my god
oh i will hoon there are only two types
of things in our world
things that should be resisted and
things that should be accepted
and i believe this oracle is something
to accept
[Music]
okay yep okay all right
glad that is there to help us solve
crimes
oh i missed his slip madman do you think
we're crazy for believing everything
that's skeletal yeah
um i do yeah no for sure no we're not
crazy
not one bit this is our destiny that's
all cool and i'll show why you asked me
then
but i shouldn't need to explain that to
you okay rude
okay the one who fired the pistol at
heaven
firing pistols at the sky might be a
rather common occurrence for the south
remember fire the pistol at heaven young
guns
1988 directed by christopher kane
there's that great scene where emilio
estevez keeps firing his cult
m1877 up at the sky but that film took
place in new mexico didn't it
and the oracle probably isn't referring
to a situation like that yeah that's
pretty obscure and bizarre um
it's got to be for some purpose other
than an attack
epistle in heaven raising a pistol up to
the sky
then slowly pulling the trigger i don't
know kind of sounds like that
start to erase don't you agree okay
where would a race start in any of these
[ __ ] locations
the farm maybe
we're currently running a race here i
didn't know that
and the one who started this murder
investigation is indeed
the one who fired the pistol in heaven
okay in other words the person who first
discovered the body
according to the files lisa's body was
discovered by chuck thompson
a crawfish farmer yeah it's actually
pretty weird that we haven't spoken to
chuck yet
he apparently works out of a fishing hut
located in the marshes south of the
bayou let's go pay him a visit
that's a good idea who knows yeah we
might even get to see some crawfish
exciting what why isn't the murderer the
one who started this race
zack this isn't like you of course the
murderer isn't the one who started the
race the murderer is running it
they're currently in first place and
they're breaking all the rules okay
any more objections zach i didn't say
anything
all right well glad we figured that out
within the white hall of
beds hospital there are only a few
establishments that have a whole hall's
worth of beds
especially in a small town i'm sure
you've already got a pretty good idea
about what the answer the hospital
beds all lined up only an amateur would
hear that and think it must be referring
to a brother okay so it's probably gonna
be the
i mean come on who would ever use white
hall
as a symbol for a bordello no a white
house refers to the same place no matter
what country i mean that's the church
but why would there be beds in the
church you never disappoint me zach
why why you got a hall of beds as a
church it's a medical facility
oh okay they invite their patients into
rooms full of beds
where they're tended to by doctors and
nurses clad in one okay why is that in
the church it's
definitely a white hall where people are
invited into beds
is this making sense to anyone else
you always manage to impress me with
your intuition
how what does that have to do with the
church do you think that they wrote it
with a hospital in mind and then were
like ah we don't we can't map that out
so really counting on you here zack
and i know i'll always be able to got
you
[Music]
thank you uh don't worry about who zack
is don't worry about it don't worry
about it
[Music]
cool did i get zero dollars for
equipping that is that what that just
said it's [ __ ]
agent york you're trying to leave
without your trustworthy
sorry patty hello there patty
i'd never attempt such a thing he's such
a pleasant man i you know i was simply
engaging in a battle of wits with hoon
gone while i waited for it
yes the skeletal gentleman in the top
hat
just let that one sit for a second
okay not that story again is this how
you
always conduct your investigations no
this is the way i work okay yes sorry i
bet you can't find a single partner
not even in the entire okay patty that's
not true
i always work together with zach oh
right
zach don't worry i'll be your partner
while you're here in our town
now let's go investigate okay bye
skateboard
great
cool day well spent
everything's going excellently and
exactly as planned
let's go to the church i guess
i [ __ ] know what's happening i don't
know what's [ __ ] happening
oh hi sarah she's watching again hello
uh i don't know how to uh respond to
your
your text i'm sorry that's my sister by
the way
um just ignore the flashback part
is what i'm going to say just ignore all
of that and then just
separate them it'll make sense
how dare you say this is a bad drug trip
if this is what drug trips are like i
need to do more drugs
the load times are really bad yeah
that's what's bad about it yeah it's
just a lot of times everything else is
great thank you adam
oh [ __ ] it's daddy with the
eye brow vibrator
did he just say how's your mom that's
[ __ ] up so
yo fbi agent
yes hello and who might you be all right
anime
i came to claim the body of my
he's actually a very cool guy who was
murdered in a holding cell after
you detained her yesterday yeah i feel
like danny maybe did it
you must be the head of the clarkson
family pj clarkson
and you've come to claim the body of
galena clarkson whose dismembered corpse
was found early this morning yep
is that correct where did you learn that
galena had been murdered
i loved it just that i just learned the
news ourselves
it's brilliant this is lucari
and i i am pj
clarkson there ain't a single thing i
don't
know about this town cool so what's up
with your eye patch
i see so then you must also know about
the severed roots ritual
oh [ __ ] you just call it out i have a
question for you phillip
we suspect that galena was murdered by
someone from the clarkson family
have you given that possibility any
consideration i you know this version of
york i just love you
pieces all right danny get a haircut i
better watch your manners around my paw
shut up i like it
my bad sir
[Music]
i'll have you know i once had three
children
that's too many but i must not
have raised them very well because my
son and my eldest daughter both ran away
and never came back to me okay
the only one who stayed by my side
was my second daughter now dad
then she done married daniel here into
the family
and presented me with both an air
and his [ __ ] hair man and his face i
guess that's
[Music]
someone corrupted both galena and lee
was the son rouge was it the drugs
and i lost everything was it professor
all who was it
aside from my [ __ ] heel son-in-law that
is
that's what i do whenever someone
insults me also just you understand me
fbi galena's death is nothing but a loss
for the clarkson family
that doesn't mean the clarksons are
automatically innocent though
humans don't always act out of
self-interest do they
that mouth you're starting to sound
more and more like your mother that's
the thing i'd say to a little girl
we're leaving daniel what
but my treasures
that is pretty [ __ ] weird that they
didn't go in uh
whether you end up being an angel or a
demon
i reckon you're the man is that what the
angel is a reference to does this guy
corrupt him is that what happened is it
pj
once you finish that autopsy and we're
clear to take her home okay fair i'm
sorry i questioned it i want you to give
me a call
you've watched your face sir they're
phenomenal patty what the [ __ ]
so perfectly rural are they ominous
statements
foul-mouthed insults did anyone swear
possesses a complicated
system of communication that you just
can't find in the city
work-centric emails are so cold and
lifeless
this is what true human connections feel
like
connections as visceral as blood itself
so agent york what's next on your agenda
oh my god
the last boss may have gotten the jump
on us paddy
but i didn't let him shake my resolve i
intend to obey the skeletal gentleman's
oracles
and that's that who is the lost boss
first we should head to
either the home of the person who
discovered lisa's body or to the town's
medical facility i think i want to go to
the
medical facility which is apparently the
church
apparently i don't know how they just
snuck that up on a skateboard time you
guys you [ __ ] ready for this
this button sick
actually should check the map we're
gonna go
it's like here no no no no no no
am i not seeing it
[Music]
there yeah
you have to do a circle i think i might
have got
welcome to the open world everyone uh
what do you think these are ufos
and all the other women you've seen so
far on our travels across the states
zach i'm right this is a vast country
incredibly fast and it's mostly composed
of mountains
[ __ ] i got an itchy face
ah i broke his dial up because my face
wasn't cheap
on the grass this town has assumed it's
got to be that
bridge hanging over the body the lift
bridges are truly
rarity it reminds me of delusion i love
that they grow up what happened there
sounds exactly the same as the roads
you know this focus squirrel's gonna
fight me again no you don't stop the
[ __ ] don't steal my [ __ ]
as i drove him to the station after his
arrest he started lecturing me on the
proper way to give something
all right cool bye nope didn't mean to
do that
okay we did it
video games be happening oh my god
alakazam i would love that
alakazam's left spoon sorry
hey agent york yes just so you know
dealing with pastor sanders is gonna be
a big pain because everyone else makes
everything so easy
a big pain in the butt that's what i
said but i guess you have no choice but
to obey your oracle huh
you're catching on not gonna respond to
that well literally
okay let's do this
i can't wait to see the medical facility
apparently rows of white beds or
whatever they said
is that morgana holy [ __ ] you're right
chris it fully does sound like morgana
i hadn't even considered that
i'm not a cat
i don't like hospitals cool well good
news we're in a church soup folks up
with medicine
cut them up and then they try and act
like they're your friends
something ain't right about that you
know it goes against the laws of nature
okay plus this is a church thank you so
you got a pastor
a servant of god actually playing god
with his patients
i think you have a point there patty
these days we can either determine death
nor reproduce without the help of modern
medicine
yeah our world's become quite an
unnatural one
okay oh excuse me
is this tulsa one is lucare
you need to watch where you're going or
someone might end up tripping you
okay
that's could be professor zach it's her
the stylish woman who watched lisa doc
wow they put more effort into animating
that physically than they did
anything else in this entire game the
whole time
uh hi there pastor we've met already
would you mind letting go of me
i'm in a bit of a hurry right now so
pitiful this pastor just assault me
the lord hungers
ah here we go again
uh what pitiful
truly pitiful my little lamb
oh his eyes are pretty no neither zach
nor i oh
so beautiful so beautiful just
okay what is specifically is pitiful
the lord hungers okay you said that one
can of spam one can of red beans
and one can of spinach you are to offer
up the taboo
trinity taboo don't you mean the holy
oh how i pity you what
unlike us humans the law never airs
what now my pitiful agent bring forth
the taboo trinity
at once for it is the will of the lord
our
god see i told you this was going to be
a pain
i don't know if that's what i'd call it
but zach and i need to go after that
stylish woman
too late now we need to obey god's will
oh my god
the hungers come on hurry it up
we need to go well zack i don't know
what to say
first an oracle and now an order from
god spitting speeds this is a trial
something else the ticket to the goddess
either way it looks like we have no
choice but to gather the taboo trinity
i guess it just goes to show that small
towns are always filled with the bizarre
and unpredictable
[Music]
why does zuli frida sell spinach
oh my [ __ ] god
[Music]
you know sometimes they just have to
take the time to process what what's
happening
in this game i went to
a church that i was told was a medical
facility turns out that was true
because the man in the reflection in the
police station told me to
and i came here and the pastor yelled at
me about being pitiful and said the lord
hungers
and told me that i have to buy spam
spinach and beans which is
the holy taboo is that what he said
okay yeah no it makes sense sorry i just
have to think about it for a second but
no uh my bad i actually do completely
understand it makes
it makes perfect sense oh my god
oh holy [ __ ] best written game i've ever
played
my [ __ ] god
uh yes it absolutely is deep
you're 100 right the batman who loves
there's a lot to to think about you know
i i wanted to formally take back every
time that i've ever said
the premonition is bad it's not it's
just
different it's just
very unique
okay let's [ __ ] go then we gotta
get food for the lord he be hungry
and we can't have that because it's
incredible bridges
yeah he's going to start talking about
preachers again
hey wanna
[Music]
all right i don't really know where i'm
going i guess maybe getting free from
the warehouse
this is the deep snow uh-huh i feel it
every time that multiplayer yes we've
been over there
yeah totally oh okay i couldn't get up
that
that literal ramp but going across brows
is that a jump rope
oh my god oh my god oh my god i want it
so bad i want it so bad
[Music]
i mean i made it to where i have to be
it just wasn't like
as cool as i hoped so
mama really
okay zach it's time to put our skills to
the test
what i already did that dog
but i already jumped over it
why did we could just crawl under that
or go around
well zack it seems as if we've reached
an impact i disagree
it doesn't really seem that way i'm
afraid we won't be able to proceed any
further like this you broke the [ __ ]
skateboard you douchebag
zakari tiger to dc eagle is everything
all right
hello melvin sadly my darling just gave
out on me
you're darling you mean
yes that's right my beloved skateboard
he's perfect i know the chances are slim
but do you happen to know of any
establishment this basically is the
deadly
netflix series let's be real please i
hope this doesn't defend you
neither zach nor i would ever dare to
assume that a remote country town like
this would have a skateboard shop in it
but perhaps you have at least one
eccentric who likes to tinker with them
in their spare time
i know just the person
double bass player by night trick
master by day god blessed her with two
talents and her name is
emma sanders okay
emma that's right
she's past the santa's adopted daughter
and was also lisa clarkson's best friend
emma really knows her stuff she's got
tools and a mountain of parts
so i'm sure she'll be able to help great
how do i get them
melvin please teleport me zack i never
thought we'd find our very own
skateboard mentor out here in the sticks
let's head straight to emma well i could
have just
walked underneath
it's fine it's fine it is
absolutely what is it zach why didn't i
just ask the sheriff to tow away the old
cars why didn't i just walk around it
but isn't it obvious i want to overcome
this obstacle using my
own strength
okay i guess that in theory answers a
lot of the questions i have about this
game
in fact i want a sword okay look i can't
argue with that
if that's what you want to do i cannot
tell you that you're wrong
[Music]
um can we go straight to emma though
please how close is this [ __ ] gonna be
these are all really far away
[ __ ] okay where are you where's emma
i mean she should be on my map right
[ __ ] hell
she's probably at the church
maybe what is this
oh i didn't mean to do that
yeah get rid of that uh
okay maybe this will tell me i'm a
skateboard
where do i [ __ ] gotta
run to wherever i'm [ __ ] going
oh no
oh it's there why are you so far away
okay so we need to get to the church
fast travel to the diner
oh my god even getting into the church
is gonna take like 10 years
uh why have you done this no if there's
no sprint
that's the button for me trying to
skateboard why has this happened
i laughed out loud at your comment
alicia you can
sprint how do i sprint
what button to sprint
it's right upper for some reason all
right that's helpful
what is this
okay
didn't know that was the thing but it'll
stop the [ __ ] squirrels from bullying
me oh yeah stamina
cool all the best games have stamina
bars
short sprints why does nobody in video
games know how to run at all ever
that's my question
am i going the wrong way i thought that
looked like the church
that's not church church is around the
corner from here though isn't it
uh it's just up this way okay
all right boss we got this it's not that
far you could run
200 meters you could
you could you could uh you won't
but you totally could oh what if i don't
have the dinah fast travel thing
activated
i mean going to the hotel would still be
closer so
am i disappointed by this game not even
a little bit no
he does sound like he's wearing while
she's
[ __ ] hell
all right all right this is what we want
oh my god
um no this this game is the biggest
piece of [ __ ] that i've ever played but
uh is it disappointing not even a little
bit
no it's incredible all right
i want to use it let's go take me to
there yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh thank you alex yeah i uh i'll keep
making videos like that for sure
okay we have to go
oh i should make my way point that'll
help because we just got to run the
whole goddamn way there
it's not gonna be that bad all right
that's not what i pictured myself doing
at 10 a.m on a wednesday morning
just running 10 meters and then stopping
but uh you win some you listen folks
come on buddy why's that happened
oh my god it's 10 am in game
frame rates everybody loves
frame rates
okay oh my god you're so close oh my god
you're right there
oh baby fix my [ __ ] skateboard before
i
quit the game okay please emma please
help me
and then i'm gonna buy some spam and
beans and spinach for your dad
because apparently the lord hungers i
don't know dude just what i was told
just what i was told
i don't make the rules
okay gotta go around i guess
it's arbitrary fences everywhere here is
fine just a minor obstacle we'll make it
work
who's following me oh it's uh it's patty
who is my
partner in crime basically or partner in
anti-crime i suppose would be more apt
she's just friend i'm not being stole
she's just
slug nope wow she really
wow
patty that's [ __ ] terrifying we need
to talk about that
once i fix my skateboard we're gonna
have a [ __ ] sit-down discussion about
that [ __ ] you just pulled
you used creepy [ __ ]
i don't trust you anymore use boogie
[ __ ]
nope but i like any of that you
shouldn't be allowed to do any of that
that's not a good time okay oh this is
literally the pasta sauce oh that's
right did say was
it was his daughter i almost had a
thousand dollars
i could buy so many cigarettes with that
that's not where we were standing hey
agent york i feel like someone's in
there to me emma
let's go and see okay let's go and see
look how cool you are that's how i
dressed when i was a teenager like 100
percent
a beanie like that is literally how i
dress
i'm kind of busy here i probably said
[ __ ] like that too
hi emma hi there are you emma
yeah who are you
francis york morgan i'm an fbi special
agent
please call me york that's what everyone
calls me it's true
agent york
so what does the fbi want with little
favorite skateboard
i already broke these bikes i know about
these
emma i haven't come here to talk to you
about lise although i suppose it's
sort of connected in a way you got great
eyebrows my darling is broken
and i need you to fix her you call your
board your darling
i've never heard that one before
[ __ ] off patty i saw what you did i
haven't forgotten about
it that quickly i'll try and assess the
damage
she just clapped in the background is
that gonna fix my skateboard my dolling
i mean sir
i sure hope so
do we do it did we fix it
i replaced all your trucks wheels and
gave you some brand new duct tape
also you were missing a tail guard so
i'll put one on for you excellent
that way you should be able to do a few
tricks here and there without any risk
of damage
i can do tricks now well what do you
think
it's beautiful emma the wheels were
scraped down and the base plate screws
were all about to fall out
oh and the axles were also warped it was
pretty much in
critical condition
now what i want to know is how did it
get that way
well my car was stolen on my way here
from houston i didn't actually know that
so
i switched over to my darling and rode
her here instead
you know you're crazier than you look
thank you
emma would you mind answering another
crazy question for me
i want to use this board to soar
literally
i'm not sure if you mean would you mind
teaching me a trick that would allow me
to do so [ __ ] yes skateboard tricks dude
you mean you want to do a wall-e oh
well i'd be happy to teach you how but
it's too cramped in here you could just
go to the road there's literally nobody
out there ever
oh i know
you want to learn too
you sure seems like you're interested
whatever i know you're just gonna come
along anyway
a woman literally just got murdered
inside of a prison
and this is what we're doing with that
time
good point alex she's an idiot emma is
pretty i agree
all right cool okay
will do what
oh my god okay agent york now we should
have enough room to practice
i'll show you how it's done first then
you just practice till you learn how to
do it
okay great
you physically showing me doesn't
actually teach me
i feel like i need to maybe know button
crumbs
also why is she not tilting at all
that's not how skateboard
why you you literally just
showed me her doing the thing without
telling me
there you go that's what i needed
okay skateboarding minigames
okay sure yeah great
okay oh my
like god maybe
a little bit earlier i'm not sure if i'm
doing it right
okay
what is this sonic uh uh yo come on come
on y'all come on
yep yeah you gotta aim control like butt
just break here just do a little break
yep okay turn around as soon as you open
into something
i'm pretty sure it's stuck out it says
at the right time but i'm not entirely
sure of what it means by that
why are you telling me to give up uh
can i not get between these is that okay
that is what you're telling me i've got
to do this one properly
is it yeah
when do i press it now oh okay
i got it great [ __ ] hell
oh if we just keep it real slow
then we're gonna break we're just gonna
hey i'm sure sonic had these problems
when he was starting out too
you know
[Music]
oh this game's so bad okay oh well i
could go up there
i guess
oh it did give me a prompt that time am
i stuck now
did i get myself stuff oh
come on buddy oh if only you could just
there you go look at you
i'm proud
too much speed man you getting wind
lines okay we're gonna find
the last two
where's it just one oh there are two
they're really far apart
um all right yep remember sonic had
these issues too
no if only you could turn better it's
fine
stop here ramp
all right cool
why is this in this game a woman was
literally chopped up inside of a
jail cell i just don't know that this is
the best use of our time
okay yeah got trapped i think can i go
through
because it seems like i should be able
to oh i can't okay
all right that's the ending we've done
it
[Music]
[Music]
why
okay oh yeah sure i'll take it i don't
need sunscreen yet we've already been
over this i'm not sunburned
i can't wait to come back here and max
that out um but uh
right now you know woman died
so does that
was considering potentially
[Music]
that was perfect agree to disagree
yeah thank you emma i only learned that
new trick thanks to your guidance yeah
she was super helpful
now i'm sure that zach and i will be
able to reach our destination without
any trouble at all
thank you for assisting in the
investigation glad to be a service
if your board breaks again or you feel
like customizing it a bit more
just stop on by my work this game really
has it all
it really has it all i'm pretty much
always there during the day
i'm also taking some time off school
because of what happened with lise
convenient skating and playing music are
the only things that help me escape the
pain of losing
now i feel bad that's fair enough
sorry about that
zach did you see the expression on her
face just now
she works hard to act cheerful but she's
yet another person who was hurt by the
tragedy
lisa's death is like wildfire spreading
embers of sadness throughout the entire
town
cool what are you doing paddy [ __ ] off
with that i don't trust you anymore
incense has been unlocked now i can do
cool tricks that's what i was saving for
oh my god stop
okay where do we want to go right now
uh
i forget where the objective was
i'll just follow one of the waypoints i
suppose it's fine
cool art
activate this first
oh my god
i don't want to use it actually right
now we're just going to skateboard to
the nearest
objective which looks like it's going to
be the one
that's just over a thousand right
so what do you think of it this i'm
talking about him
a skeletal gentleman
is it clear that's what my soul
like a boss who appeared in a variety of
different films
my mind must be overlapping with the
skeleton
do you remember his name where is bridge
am i stuck over here
there's purchase that bridge death
were you thinking about galena and all
the other women we've seen so far on our
travels across the states
zach i'm right all right this is a vast
country incredibly fast and it's mostly
composed of mountains and deserts and
farmland
small towns scattered about here and
there that's how america lives together
to the scale of this entire country new
york
chicago and l.a are all microscopic
sometimes they even feel like figments
of my imagination
think back to what las vegas driving up
i-15
it was a mirage tv and movies dress
meanwhile american women become
fascinated by the gorgeous city lights
that are drawn together are you not
getting puffed
like are you not shot of breath at
in the all all they find are ghosts
leave their eyes
just to that blinding light they realize
there's nothing but vanity and lust
surrounding them it's some heavy [ __ ]
man
okay then they quickly try to satisfy
themselves
we need to find the person who's hiding
behind galena
drag them out into the blazing southern
sun
what just happened
who asked about any of that i don't
oh my god okay okay
jesus christ
very good jordan this is the deep south
i can't wait to talk to this one about
cajun food for uh 15 minutes
[Music]
the air out there don't feel right today
you feel it too
does it feel too deep too south
no
okay even this is a lot of text you
could have made this so much shorter
they are talking about it for 15 minutes
again it's just not voice acting now
[Music]
okay
she's telling me she wants me to take a
cajun dish to put it in something about
refilling my stabida all right
sounds intriguing apparently okay make
it for me
oh my god she can't make it that quick
it needs ingredients
i'm trying to get ingredients for
someone else right now do you have beans
spinach or spam
she wants grit no you also why does
everyone need [ __ ] ingredients
she needs one rice just one grate of
rice
oh maybe i can do that
okay okay got it okay
you need rice okay why is this a part of
this game at all
i'm talking after the main quest dude
i don't think i need any of these things
[Music]
um alexis could i have some red beans
there we go i guess oh my lord sorry
honey but no can do we only serve red
beans and rice on
son of a [ __ ]
a meal you eat when you're busy like
folks usually
are on monday son of a [ __ ] it's been a
tradition here
in louisiana for as long can i get a
south check is that true
do you eat beans at rice on a monday
when you're really busy
anyone from louisiana um
is it true south check yeah
that does happen on a monday though
specifically it can't be any of the day
because you are extra busy on a monday
so you wanna
yeah okay okay good cool thank you guys
thank you okay cool
wait tradition zack
this is it the deep south telling us
that
we need to obey tradition here and come
back on monday [ __ ] hell
you know what i should leave it there i
will find
someone to give me spinach and someone
to give me spam
for the pastor who said the lord hungers
next time i think we've been streaming
for
yeah about two hours two hours ish i
gotta work out then i gotta go to bed
oh i just got wet grated rice you know
uh we'll keep making it at work
um i'm planning to stream again tomorrow
so i'm probably gonna do a ghost of
tsushima
uh q a stream thing which will probably
be really quick and then do more deadly
premonition later in the day perhaps
perhaps we'll see we'll see we'll see
that's the plan it's finished in the
vending machine thank you for that david
does the vending machine only operate on
a monday because that's when it's busy
or whatever oh my god
[ __ ] ridiculous all right yup i'm
gonna
i'm gonna head off you have a good night
everyone thank you for joining me
it's been a very exciting journey
um
yep